le Godzilla de 1998 est-il vraiment plus
réaliste que le Godzilla classique
japonais comme le design qu'on rencontre
dans Godzilla minus one sorti tout
récemment alors les deux designs sont
fondamentalement inspirés des dinosaures
ça il y a aucun doute mais la différence
est réellement dans la posture le
Godzilla de 1998 a une posture
pronograde avec la colonne vertébrale à
l'horizontale perpendiculaire à l'axe
des jambes très proche du design qu'on
peut voir des dinosaures teréropodes de
Jurassic Park qui sont considérés comme
étant très réalistes alors que le
Godzilla de Minus One est directement
inspiré du Godzilla de 1954 une époque
où on représentait les dinosaures comme
traînant la queue au sol et aussi et
surtout une époque où il n'y avait pas
les effets numériques permettant
justement de représenter des dinosaures
en posture pronograde et c'est pour ça
que ce Godzilla dans minus One est
représenté avec une posture ortho grade
c'est-à-dire la même qu'un être humain
parce que à l'époque en 1954 il fallait
qu'un être humain se glisse dans le
costume de Godzilla et donc la colonne
vertébrale de Godzilla est parallèle à
l'axe de ses jambes c'est la posture
orthograde mais cela veut-il dire pour
autant que le Godzilla classique
japonais a un design forcément désué et
bien il y a deux choses qu'il faut
prendre en compte pour relativiser cette
conclusion la première c'est
l'allométrie les animaux de petite
taille ne sont pas des modèles réduits
des animaux de grande taille il y a des
différences fondamentales dans la façon
dont leur corps est organisé
généralement les animaux de grande
taille vont avoir des têtes
proportionnellement plus petites que les
animaux de petite taille et par exemple
les animaux de petite taille vont avoir
proportionnellement des plus grands yeux
que les animaux de très grande taille
cette hométrie on la rencontre même au
sein d'une même espèce pendant son
développement ça s'appelle l'allométrie
ontogénétique un être humain bébé n'est
pas le modèle réduit d'un être humain à
adulte un être humain adulte a un très
grand corps et une petite tête comparé à
un être humain bébé qui a une très
grosse tête mais un tout petit corps et
en terme d'allométrie et bien le
Godzilla de 1998 est littéralement juste
un dinosaure teréropode qu'on a agrandi
malgré le fait qu'il soit des milliers
de fois plus grand qu'un dinosaure
théropode que le plus grand des
dinosaures théropodes même Godzilla de
1998 n'est jamais qu'un dinosaure
théropode qu'on a agrandi directement
sans prendre en compte l'allométrie
alors que le godilla japonais lui il a
une toute petite tête et un très gros
corps donc son design prend en compte le
phénomène d'hallométrie l'allométrie ça
s'applique aussi aux os les os des
animaux de grande taille sont
proportionnellement plus fragiles que
les os des animaux de petite taille par
exemple vous pouvez lancer une souris du
haut du toit d'une maison la souris
atterrira sur ses pattes et partira en
courant alors qu'un cheval risque de se
casser une jambe en tombant uniquement
de de sa propre hauteur les animaux plus
grands sont proportionnellement plus
fragiles et notamment leurs EOS sont
proportionnellement plus fragile et
ainsi et bien les os de Godzilla
risquent de se rompre à tout moment à
chaque fois qu'il bouge à chaque fois
qu'il fait un pas en avant la pression
du poids de son corps sur la jambe qui
reste au sol et qui est en train de
pousser risque de faire exploser ses os
à chaque pas et si il tombe ce Godzilla
il s'écrasera au sol et tout son corps
sera broyé sous son propre poids
exactement comme une baleine échouée et
de fait le Godzilla de Minus One est
beaucoup plus réaliste que le Godzilla
de 1998 puisqu'il se déplace extrêmement
lentement extrêmement
précautionneusement et il ne court pas
parce que courir met une énorme pression
sur les jambes de l'animal quand il se
déplace et surtout quand on court et
bien on risque de tomber surtout si on a
une posture pronograde comme le Godzilla
de 1998 et comme à chaque impact au sol
les EOS de ses jambes risquent de se
briser sous la pression et bien en fait
le Godzilla de Minus One est de fait
bien plus réaliste que le Godzilla de
1998 parce qu'il ne court pas alors que
le Godzilla de 1998 lui est capable de
courir et ça étant donné sa taille étant
donné ses dimensions ça devrait lui
faire littéralement exploser les jambes
et la deuxième raison pour laquelle
Godzilla japonais est plus réaliste que
le Godzilla de 1998 et bien c'est la
gravité le Godzilla japonais est bien
mieux équipé pour soutenir son propre
poids il se tient droit dans cette
posture orthograde ce qui envoie toutes
les contraintte lié à son poids
directement dans ses jambes il se sert
de sa queue comme d'une troisième jambe
comme d'un trépied pour dissiper encore
plus son poids dans plus de surface au
sol et ce qui lui permet aussi quand il
marche et bien d'avoir toujours deux
points d'appui au sol même quand il
soulève une jambe à chaque pas qu'il
fait conscient de la fragilité de ses
eau il se déplace excessivement
lentement c'est pas seulement pour un
effet dramatique et pour avancer au son
de la marche de Godzilla la la musique
épique de la marche de Godzilla c'est
aussi et surtout parce que bah ça risque
de le tuer si jamais il va trop vite et
encore plus important ses jambes sont
d'une épaisseur incroyable il a des
énormes cuisses qui lui permettent de
résister aux contraintes démentielles
imposées par son poids et tout cela
donne à Godzilla minus one une forme
générale en forme de cône avec des très
grosses jambes et une petite tête qui
est très stable à sa base très stable
sur ses appuis et donc il ne risque pas
de se déséquilibrer et il ne risque pas
de fait de tomber et comme je le disais
de de s'écraser complètement sous son
propre poids à l'inverse la forme du
Godzilla de 1998 est directement inspiré
d'un dinosaure théropode qui était
adapté à la course c'est un design qui
cherche la chute vers l'avant pour
favoriser l'accélération c'est un design
qui fondamentalement est déséquilibrer
une forme générale comme ça pour un
animal aussi gros c'est du quasi
suicidaire et si arrivriz à ce moment de
la vidéo vous n'êtes toujours pas
convaincu que le Godzilla japonais est
plus réaliste que le Godzilla de 1998 et
bien il est temps de faire quelques
calculs les paléontologues adorent lié
par le calcul le poids du corps d'un
animal disparu et les dimensions de ces
EOS pourquoi et bien tout simplement
parce que les paléontologues travaillent
uniquement à partir d'ossement fossilisé
donc pour eux arriver à reconstituer
l'allure générale d'un animal et
notamment son poids et bien ça doit
passer obligatoirement par la case
dimension des eos et de fait il y a
plein de paléontologues qui se sont
intéressés à la question comment arriver
à estimer le poids d'un animal
uniquement à partir des mensurations de
ses eau et pour ça on se base sur les
animaux modernes les animaux modernes
dont on a d'un côté le poids mais aussi
de l'autre côté les Osem et on dresse
comme ça de grandes tendances on appelle
ça des courbes de régression et les
espèces éteintes en général vont se
placer dans ces grandes tendances pour
arriver à estimer leur poids à partir de
leurs eau fondamentalement c'est plus ou
moins le même principe qu'un produit en
croix et donc grâce à ça les
paléontologues ont réussi à estimer que
l'une des métriques les plus importantes
pour arrivriver à estimer le poids d'un
dinosaure bipède ça va être la
circonférence de la section du fémur
donc vous prenez le fémur vous le coupez
et la circonférence de cette section va
être directement proportionnelle au
poids de l'animal pourquo bah parce que
vous êtes en train de regarder un animal
bipède et donc tout son poids est
soutenu par ces deux fémures ces deux
seuls et unique fémur donc la
circonférence du fémur va être
directement proportionnelle à la
robustesse du fémur à la capacité de se
fait mur à soutenir le poids de l'animal
donc généralement les équations des
paléontologues vont permettre d'estimer
un poids à partir de la circonférence du
fémur mais du coup on peut inverser ces
équations et pouvoir estimer la CIR
conférence du fémur de Godzilla à partir
de son poids canoniquement donné dans le
film Godzilla minus one à 200000 tonnes
et si on utilise du coup un poids de
20000 tonnes appliqué sur ces équations
cela nous donne un fé mur estimé à une
circonférence de 9 m pour Godzilla voilà
pourquoi Godzilla minus One a des jambes
aussi grotesquement
gigantesque certes c'est peut-être parce
que quelqu'un doit rentrer dans le
costume mais c'est aussi parce que il ne
pourrait pas tenir debout s'il avait des
jambes fines comme des baguettes
exactement comme on voit dans le
Godzilla de 1998 et d'autres équations
nous disent que un fémur qui aurait une
circonférence de 9 m devrait normalement
avoir une longueur de 17 m alors il n'y
a pas de mesure officielle de la taille
du fémur de Godzilla minus one mais
d'après les infographies qu'on peut voir
sur internet c'est à peu près dans le
bon ordre de grandeur d'ailleurs 17 m
c'est juste un peu plus qu'un/4 de la
hauteur du godzill la MINUS one qui est
donné à à peu près une cinquantaine de
mètres de haut or si on le compare à un
autre animal orthograde comme l'être
humain par exemple et bien chez l'être
humain le fémur fait aussi un/art de la
hauteur totale du corps donc même en
appliquant ces calculs paléontologique
très savant et bien on retrouve que
Godzilla minus One est bel et bien très
réaliste Godzilla minus One est en fait
si réaliste qu'on se demanderait presque
si les gens responsables de son design
n'ont pas poussé le souci du détail
jusqu'à aller consulter la littérature
paléontologique et faire ses calculs
eux-mêmes pour nous donner ce qui est ni
plus ni moins que le Godzilla le plus
réaliste
possible